said on the on the channel oh this song
is stuck in my head well praise god
yeah right you know you've got that word
stuck in your mind
and so you'll be able to use it when god
needs to pull it there and you know
if you didn't put it there
what do you get when you cross bible
memorization
and media find out on this episode of
led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness hey everybody
welcome to
led live where we are going to actually
share some light we're not going to
expose any darkness on this show
yeah we normally do but uh you know
today's a special show we
actually are going to talk about the
positive uses of media
i'm sure you if you're if you're watched
our channel before you're probably not
unfamiliar with as many times as we uh
literally hammer media but
today we have an awesome guest ricky
carter thanks for coming on our show
today
yeah we're excited to see um what you're
doing with media because
i believe that it is very important for
us to commit
bible text to memory and i think in
today's day and age we're so used to
relying on well i can just look it up on
my phone
right um you know like if you've ever
read anything from
anyone from the 1800s like if they
were writing anything about the bible
they were like throwing
in their bible texts in between all the
writing like those people
knew their bibles and it's like we get
to our day and age and i feel like
we've kind of gotten a little lazy
people remember whole books of the bible
like it was normal yeah and so you've
come up with an awesome solution for
that
and tell us a little bit about the
ministry that you're involved in here
praise god thank you well the ministry
is titled
hide it in your heart and i found that
for me i had a situation where i was
wanting to witness to someone
and man scott i just couldn't remember
the text right right and i know i need
to give a reason for what i believe
but i was in that situation i was like
oh it's in the bible someplace
yeah yeah it's in the new testament in
the old testament
that just wasn't working right and
i found that i need to memorize god's
word and so i started
using an app well first before that i
started using
business cards and writing scripture on
the back of all business cards
that's cool and that was helping a
little bit and
but i found that i needed something else
found this app and the app had a game on
it to help you memorize scripture
and and had a way you could record your
voice
and i would play it back and that helped
a little bit
but it still just wasn't sticking in my
mind and i
i can remember how
in reading some spirit of prophecy in
the last days
there's gonna come a time when we're not
gonna have our bibles with us
that's right and we're going to need to
be able to
only call it from memory so i'm thinking
man i'm going to be in a situation
i already have been in a situation where
i couldn't memorize the text i couldn't
share it
what there has been a time when i was
able to memorize scripture and well how
did i do that
and it was when i was younger it was
through song
and so i was like okay well i can sing
well let me write a tune for a scripture
so i started off doing that made a tune
and i said oh this is great it's helped
me memorize it
shared it with a friend and he thought
that was cool
he then shared a scripture with me he
played
guitar that kind of stepped it up a
notch
and i was like man like well i can play
the guitar but
not or and piano but not as quick as he
could so i said well i can sing all four
parts so i started doing that
and that whole process as i started
coming up with all these scripture songs
and then sharing with people i found
that i would be able to be in a
situation and then i could
share god's word a lot easier and
and then i said okay well how can i get
this out to more
people well i'm a i'm a designer an
animator
that's what i do for a living and
there's an advertisement for adobe that
had
the software called adobe character
animator
we use that we've used it okay great
software and so when that first was
coming out i was thinking man that's a
cool piece of software
i wish i had a project that i could use
to well that i could do so i could use
this software and the lord was like he
pricked in my mind
yeah you do have a project take all
those scripture songs that you have and
make
animated scripture songs i was like
that's a good idea yeah right and i just
quickly instead of creating the
character on my own
i wanted to just do something very quick
so i just used an emoji
it chose that animated that put it out
there with one of the first scripture
songs isaiah 65
24 got great response from it
and so that's kind of how it all started
because one of my clients they saw it
and they said hey this is fabulous love
it
can you hands make 10 yeah
i was like okay yeah i can do that
and that's kind of how it all started
and and from there i've been able to
i was just on prayer meeting the other
night and
the pastor asked me to read
romans 5 8
and i said oh yeah i can do that and god
demonstrate his own love toward us
and that while we were still
sinners christ died for us
christ died for us romans chapter
5 and verse 8. that's awesome so classic
example of
just being able to use god's word
call it up from memory and be able to
bless
others myself right it's called it's in
there it's in there
so i want to play a little bit of a clip
you have a little
video that it shows this example if you
guys haven't seen it yet this is really
neat and
you guys will get an idea of what he's
talking about
hey everyone would you like a closer
walk with christ
memorizing scripture is key to growing
your relationship with him
check out some of our fun and memorable
scripture songs
he first loved us
we loved because he first loved us
by bread alone dropped by every word
that proceedeth
out of the mouth of god it is
jesus christ
[Music]
at your side
at your right hand
but it shall not come
[Music]
which today is in the field
and tomorrow tomorrow is thrown
into the oven how much more will he
clothe you owe you
on our website and youtube channel we
will creatively
help you hide god's word in your heart
so subscribe to our channel today
and learn how you can hide it in your
heart
that's fine so you have a youtube
channel i do i do so it's like just a
website
or a facebook page you're gonna write a
picture got a youtube channel hide it in
your heart
and the website is how to in your heart
dot tv and you can find it on
us on facebook that looks like it really
took off because you were talking about
just you and a friend but i heard like
a bunch of different people a bunch of
different styles yeah so that's really
cool oh what a blessing that was
one of the songs was on facebook and
this one the first video you saw this
couple
she saw it because she's friends with
the one of the guys
and so she reached out and said hey how
do i i'd like to be a part of this
she's in england wow so she joined
another guy he saw it on ar tv
their their site he reached out chris
he's on he teaches in california
he reached out joined and and and that's
kind of how it's been going people have
been
reaching out and wow people love god's
word and hey let's hide it in our hearts
it's so amazing god gave you an idea and
he's bringing all the elements together
seems like for you people are reaching
out and it's growing bigger and bigger
and also i was hearing different genres
as well
i'm curious what's your creative process
in making these things so yes we have
the scripture so the script is written
out
but what about the music styles and you
know composing
right for me i go to
the well of creativity okay and that's
god
god is the creator amen and so
every song that i do i said god please
just give me
a smidget of your creativity and
i know i'll be able to do wonders and he
does it's it's amazing
how i'll bring a scripture to him
and the tunes just start flowing in my
mind
and even little accents this is one song
ezekiel 20 verses 12 and 20.
i was just laughing to myself when
he said ricky now add this this in here
in the song
amen just add that in this it's like a
little accent to the song i'm like
yeah yeah guys that that's great that's
going to work
and so for me it's totally god who gives
me
the ideas the creativity for it and i
believe it's the same way for the
for the other ones who are working with
me you know what i think is really cool
is um i think of david you know sitting
out there watching the sheep
and he's just like sitting there playing
the harp you know or whatever he's got
um and and just humming along on tombs
and and
and really he was singing scriptures you
know um i can't wait to get to heaven
and actually like
sit down and dave like david play me one
of those songs that you're playing you
know and
just hear the little riff or the little
tune that he's gone and uh i think it's
such a fantastic way to learn the bible
amen praise god
i'm sure all these are different links
and different levels of complication but
on average how would you
how long do you think it takes you to
make one of these videos
just coming up with a tune sometimes
takes a week
sometimes the lord gives it to me in an
hour
it it ranges when it's coming down to
the production side of it
well i'm having to illustrate the person
because i'm the first one
was the emoji but the rest of them i'm
illustrating it
that takes a little bit longer i'm
saying about
i don't know five five hours
eight hours because i'm doing not just
the front face i'm doing the different
head positions
and you have to make the mouths for all
those different positions
and at least for these two because i can
flip it
over here so that helps me out and then
so after i've got the character
created then it's a matter of i don't
have to do it all the time you know get
that done once
and then it's a matter of animating the
mouth
and what's really great about the
software is i can put the
voices in there it does the mouth
movements for me
and then i had to animate the the body
of course and
and i have i have some all in all
about five four four four days in about
an hour or two a day i guess kind of i
got a full-time job that i'm doing
right in the evening time or early in
the morning right
alex knows all about that
usually in about three days there's
sometimes when
i'm like friday morning i'm getting up
early and it's a long day
um but i would say if you're not
including
the illustrating the character i would
say about
20 hours at the max um
and yeah it's a significant amount of
time like i think that's that's
in our experience of working with media
i don't think the average person
realizes what goes into it you know they
they look at it and they just go oh
you just throw in the computer right and
it all just sort of falls in line and
comes out in a couple of minutes right a
minute
of video can take us weeks sometimes and
you know to talk about the animation
process because we kind of went through
this without yeah with our animation i
was watching and i was like whoa he's
doing some cool stuff because
we we were just learning it and trying
to get by with some simple
hand motions and stuff but i saw that
you had like flipping of the hand and
stuff like that yeah
i i liked all the little like you know i
was paying attention to that and
people clapping along with them but like
scott was talking about you know it can
take a long time for
one short thing because for one you're
working with a program and your computer
probably
is not like hollywood computer you know
so you
as you're rendering all these things it
takes a long time and
i'm i'm amazed at how fast you're
whipping it up i i don't want to get too
far off track but i've heard you say
that you were like a professional
animator did you do
stuff like this before or what i do my
day job
is motion graphics okay
and i also do a lot of video editing
and so but my degree is in graphic art
design wow
and but i got into video right out of
college
and so i didn't do any character
animation
i would hire people to to do it for me
because back then
we were they're actually yeah drawing
drawing at all
painstakingly i mean if you watch videos
of how they actually made cartoons back
then
i mean it was unreal it was like you
know transparent
move the eyebrows a little bit onion
skinning oh yeah i mean it took a day
just to like
blink you know and it's like they would
have died for this kind of technology
so so do you illustrate all those
backgrounds as well
no that's a stock man
i've got to find ways to get it done
quickly sure because starting in
december i i started the
afco school of um online evangelism
and the lord just they had they had on
their
memory verses that you learned each week
and so i said actually like the second
or third week i said
man it'd be great if i could just have a
scripture song for each one of these
verses
and the lord's like well why can't you
okay well can you help me with that yeah
i got you
and he just every week he's been
blessing so i said that to say
i've got scripture songs all the way
lined up till september wow
praise the lord well you definitely
picked a ministry that you have a lot of
content
because i mean the bible is quite large
do any of you guys know
any song scripture songs to music can
you sing one
music uh i can but
that's the spirit of fear but of
peace love and sound minor power there's
an easy one i know it's very short it's
quench not the spirit quench not the
spirit
first thessalonians 5 19
or 5 18 maybe okay forget the exact
reference but it's that's what i got
it's probably 5 18 now that i'm thinking
about it you guys familiar with steve
green
and his scripture song pack no i know
who steve green is
yeah okay well i grew up on his songs
and no i will not be singing
[Laughter]
what i'm just amazed by almost on a
daily basis is
this technology man like we i have a
program on my
or an app on my phone called marco polo
and i'm talking to like 12 guys from all
over
new york chicago i'm here and and
literally just
all over the place and we're we're uh
edifying each other we're doing bible
studies with each other you know and
and even speaking of bible studies
leading people into truth that don't
even live around here and now you're
talking about
working with animation and song
with people that live out of the country
i mean this is just amazing that
we can actually share the gospel to the
whole world
and get the whole world involved all
from
right here this desktop you know so i
have a lot of songs
for up until september and see i've got
to find
ways that i can do it efficiently so
illustrating all the backgrounds
totally out of the question right take a
long time because it's just me
you know i mean there's other people who
are singing it yeah and that's very
helpful in that way it doesn't sound the
same
talking about having a different variety
of music
so i've got the variety but i need to
find ways to make it efficient
so from
the stock background to
the creating the motion for
i have different um actions that are
already set so if the hand goes like
this or waves whatever
i hit that button it does that for me so
i
am i'm acting it out i'm moving back and
forth like this to get the head to move
back and forth and the body position and
that's very helpful uh um my
editing program has all my elements that
are right there
i'm just pulling in stuff and copying
and pasting
so just that all these types of presets
just helps to go by faster
so are you using premiere final cut
i'm using so adobe character animator to
do the animation
i'm using then i take it into after
effects do the compositing yeah
because um i mean i could do it all
inside of character animator
but i have all the shots
different shots composited in after
effects
then i can take those clips and then
just cut them together in the premiere
so that's a lot easier for me i think
it'd be really neat like you should make
some behind the scenes videos i don't
know maybe you've already done this
and show that process because you know i
think people would really appreciate the
amount of work and energy that goes
into that um yeah
you were talking about people who have
shown appreciation for these uh songs do
you have any stories of how people have
either utilized
the the songs or how they reached people
yes there's a
family who reached out to me and
they said oh thank you so much for these
scripture songs
my my kids and i we love
going to your channel on friday nights
for worship
and this is one of the ways that they
bring in the sabbath
is by singing the songs amen yes
to be used by god like that yeah oh
yeah love that yeah you know my my
family um
we try to sing songs like uh my wife
bought me a guitar for my 30th birthday
um needless to say it sat in the corner
of my house for about 10 years
before i actually picked it up and i
didn't realize most of those little
you know songs that you sing for little
kids are like three chords
and i was like if i knew it was this
easy i learned a long time ago
but um since then we've really tried to
incorporate music
in our worship and and family worships
in the evening and stuff like that and
i've really
enjoyed it i mean it's really fun and
all of those i grew up doing that
and all of those songs that i remember
as a kid it's like amazing how
it's in your brain and it's it's it's
like 30 years have gone by
and i can remember them like they're
yesterday yeah you know god designed us
like that yeah
since you mentioned worship when i was
growing up
i would i grew up as only child and but
i
i have two two of my cousins i kind of
grew up with
and so they're kind of like my brothers
and i'd go over to their house on friday
nights my whole family would get
together
and we'd have worship and one of the
things i remember remember was singing
we had a that was a part of our big part
of our worship
is singing and and memorizing scriptures
you
would share the scripture that that was
your favorite i remember one
my cousin one of my cousins when it came
to him when he
asked him hey what is your favorite
scripture share your scripture
he would always do jesus wept
john 11 35.
pick the shortest one
one of my favorite ones is john 14 1-3
let not your heart be troubled
you believe in god believe also
in me are the words of jesus christ
jesus christ
he says in my father's house how many
mentions if it were not so
i would have told you i go to prepare a
place
for you and if i go
and prepare a place for you i will come
again
and receive you to myself that
where i am there you may be
also praise god john 14
verses 1 through 3. that's awesome so
that some of that some of those accents
you're talking about like this
yes
[Applause]
he likes to have fun and
he will anoint us if we are willing to
use the talents that he's given us amen
in glorifying him
amen that's what i was just thinking
about too it's like god gives us all
these gifts and we can use them
for the world or for for him and i know
in my life and in your life we've
used our gifts of filmmaking or art or
t-shirt printing or whatever for the
world and it feels so good to be able to
use those gifts
because it's not like god's saying yeah
that thing that you think is fun
like you gotta lay it down he's like no
i'm gonna direct you
how i wanted you to use it it's so
amazing it is neat there's a there's an
amount of satisfaction like you said
that um we've had people come up to us
over the years and say you know
thank you so much for your guys's show
that you do on a weekly basis
we use it as our worship friday
afternoons or friday evenings
and we discuss the topics that are out
and it's really gotten our families
together and it's like you know you just
kind of sit back and you just go wow
like i don't know if we
we thought about that when we designed
this
but just the fact that that people are
being inspired to have a discussion
and then you know bringing it and
incorporate it into their worship
it's kind of a neat you know feeling
totally
just to know that you're being used by
god like that
man yeah yeah praise god well i feel
like we're all in this together and
you know um youtube is a it's an
interesting culture
um you know if you look at the most
watched youtube videos do you actually
know what they are
like what some of the most top let's say
top 10 top 20
no music videos they're music videos so
you know really honestly music is really
it resonates with people and especially
like kids shows
like you ever seen any of these kids
shows that kids like
yeah like any of your guys's kids watch
youtube shows yeah it's usually like a
dad playing with his daughters and
they're getting millions of views
right baby shark video is actually the
number one youtube video of all time now
wow it passed gangnam
oh yeah that's right that's right yeah
if you make something for children
it will get a lot of views because they
they like the repetition they'll play
let me watch it again let me watch it
again
and and that's why i think this is a
really important ministry
is because think about this if it's if
it's and i hate to use the word
entertaining because we're not doing
this to
entertain people so to say but i believe
god is very creative
i mean you you look at a flower and you
just go what is the purpose of this
flower outside of just
looking at it and it's beautiful and and
so
god is very like um you know presenting
in the way that he shows us things and
so we can use that same sort of
creativity
but to have the focus to teach them that
very words of god i think that
that that's a powerful ministry yeah i
just use the characters
to grab the attention of the viewer
and not just kids okay there are plenty
of adults who love
watching cartoons right right right so i
just use it to grab their attention and
then
to keep them there is to use the
the catchy song
and now that they're seeing okay this is
a song but now oh i'm learning
god's word and then it just can kind of
stick in their head to where people have
said
said on the on the channel oh this song
is stuck in my head well praise god yeah
right
you know you've got that word stuck in
your mind and
so you'll be able to use it when god
needs to pull it there and you know
if you didn't put it there to start
with god can't bring it back to you if
you didn't put it
right that's right moses teaching the
children of israel the ten commandments
through song
i mean he saw value in saying you know i
want them to learn
this and one of the greatest ways is to
do this through song
you know there's there's a lot of
examples of using song in
in the bible and so um you know in the
very end
revelation talks about the the the
people who make it through that final
time that sing the song of moses and the
song of the lamb right i mean
there's there's some special thing that
god has with music
and and i think it's a very powerful
tool that works the other way because
you know the enemy is using music
to mold the whole culture you know
one thing i was going to mention was you
you're taking the scripture songs to
another level because
it's not just you're putting it in the
cd player and you're listening to it
but you got the words on the screen so
now visually you're seeing the words
help you memorize
you're seeing the you know even i'm a
visual person so i
when i first started seeing how to
memorize scripture
it would be like the words and then
there'd be like little pictures that
would help you
memorize it i don't know if you've done
this before but maybe
in some of your backgrounds if it says
like heart you make a heart pop up or
something
because i'm telling you like i would do
this in some of the classes i teach at
church
for the kids whenever i have a verse i'm
trying to make them memorize
i'll i'll put a picture of whatever it's
saying you know it might be like
six pictures but it's enough to make
your brain think oh yeah
i say that and then you you fill in the
blanks or whatever love that idea
something let's take it a step further
give you a whole marketing idea right
yeah notice how we're like shaping his
job
let me tell you how to make it what do
you think about
what he said reinforcing the senses
you're hearing it you're singing it
so you hear yourself saying it as well
as you know you're hearing somebody else
say it
and you're watching it what if you had
like something for
kids to download or they write it or
just the music instrumental where you
have to sing along with it
you know like a coloring sheet for kids
i mean you're already doing the
illustration anyway
so yeah i don't know there's a product
for you
thank you so you need a whole team so
anybody's watching if you have a
skill in this area here but that's a
real that's a for a real call man
you have a real ministry you have a
full-time job and this is something that
you know people should see the value in
and get behind you whether it's
financially and it can be a full-time
job or whether it's hiring help man
um i see the value in it i wish i could
do more to help
we're pretty full-time here you know but
what i also think is an important point
to bring out is that
you have another job like this is not
just you going okay i want to make a
living doing this
youtube channel it's like i'm no doubt
you're probably laying there at
nighttime
hearing these tunes and you know you're
up early in the morning and you know
you're
you're constantly trying to find and fit
time in to make these things happen
and you know that's that's that's a
beautiful thing that that you
have put a lot of energy in it and um
you know just for the benefit of other
people that's a really good point
because if it was your full-time job
people could say
well you know it's your job but a lot of
times people ask us well what are we
supposed to do we can't watch tv we
can't play video games like there's
nothing out there to do
right right here hey why don't you
create a uh
you know you're using it to create yeah
and and other people should be doing the
same thing too
and also just a call to to you know get
involved in god's work
you may not know how to do this skill
like
you know you've been a graphic designer
i'm sure you have leg up on most people
but you you know that that takes an
amount of energy and focus to learn how
to do the youtube channel to
you know organize all this kind of stuff
you're working with other musicians
you're working with other people
i mean all of that you may not be or
know how to do
but you're saying god i'm willing just
send me and all of a sudden
you will provide the the ability to do
that he does
he does takes what you have in your hand
you know just use that
i didn't have the
instruments and well god i want to
have this song with this instrument and
i i can't
hire this person right now i don't have
that ability to do that
was oh okay ricky why won't you use this
software on your phone
wow oh really yeah it's got a violin in
there
it's got a guitar it's got a piano in
there just start off
using that amen oh okay and i did it and
praise god just use what you have yeah
that'll be what i encourage people to do
i think learning scripture anything
having to do with god's word should be
fun it should be an enjoyable experience
and i remember reading deuteronomy
chapter 11 verse 19
and the lord is saying and ye shall
teach them your children
speaking of them and the them is talking
about god's words of course
um when i sit us in that house and when
they walk us in the way and when that
lies down he's going through all these
different things that have to do with
lifestyle
i was thinking well how in the world do
you incorporate all of that in your day
talking about scripture and how perfect
is song whether you're watching or
whether it's playing in the background
while you're doing whatever or when the
song is finished talking about opening
discussion
i think that's just so powerful and
profound amen it's great
talking points well with with children
you can i i think about a time
when one of my sons uh when he was
younger
and those talking points how they can
kind of come back and help
the parent um we were i was on my way to
work
i was late he was he was going with me
and because i'm taking my day care and
so i
there's traffic all backed up i got off
one highway
try to take a another route and i got to
this other
location and when i was coming over the
highway to jump on the coming over
on the bridge to get back on the highway
to another spot
traffic was all backed up and i was like
oh man
so my son five years old at the time dad
doesn't matter
he's like well i'm late for work and
all this traffic is all over the place
and i can't get around it
it's like oh daddy can i pray for you
and i'm looking in the mirror
yes daddy why are you crying
so he prayed he said dear jesus
please help daddy to have patience amen
powerful short and powerful but yeah
those were some teachable moments
that i had with all my kids but it came
back
to help me and wow yeah i think a lot of
times
um that's what happens when we work for
god
yeah we think we're in this to actually
help other people
really you know what i mean but god is
really shaping each and every one of us
as well i have learned a ton on this
show it's like it's given
given me a reason to start looking into
this and
you know media was my idol that was that
was what i was really into
and so um god had to remove that and
then reshape that
and it's like now i can see god didn't
just take it away from me and say okay
you can't do this anymore
he just said i'm going to trade you i'm
going to take what you were doing for
the world
and i'm going to now do it for me and so
now i get to do what i do
i love to do i mean this as a as a
teenager and college age range i mean if
you ask me what do you want to do with
your life
this is what i said i wanted to do
tinker with media
and god didn't remove that he just now i
do it for him
so we serve an awesome guy we do we do
we do
awesome god awesome do you have another
one
yeah how many how many how often do you
come out with them and how many do you
think you have right now
i think i have 50 whoa
wow and i use since december
the goal is to have one once a week it
started off
by every other week the first and third
friday of the month
wow yeah but since i started this online
school bible school the lord is just
blessed with a new song and that's just
what i've come up with not to mention
those that i work with
that have sent in their songs and
they're just
they're just i'm just making my way
every week
animating them so let me ask you this is
it helpful
for you to have musicians send you their
songs
no doubt yes okay so are you looking for
um
other people who maybe have a gift or a
talent and
putting you know music to a piece of
scripture
and uh you know and it can even be
if we if on the channel if you see a
scripture that's on there it's
already been animated or the song is
already there
but you've got one for it i'm game for
that
okay so i'm learning the ukulele
i would love to put i don't know i mean
i don't have a song in mind right now
but
this is gonna be a challenge for me i'd
love to try to design something
and and i'll send it to you okay all
right we'll check it out yeah
we're gonna see scotty
make him look like a rabbit or something
i notice on your website you have
several songs that are available for
purchase
yes people can download them now this
play button here
is that previews of all these or is that
yes preview
preview so you can listen to a little
bit and say yeah do i like that or not
and then something else that's good to
know for people who are on the channel
or
on the web channel on the website or on
the youtube channel when a song comes
out
as of like two months ago
when a song comes out that first week
if they want to download the song for
free they can go to the site
and download the song for free awesome
awesome awesome
and then always on youtube for free it
is very reasonably priced you know very
comparable to anything else that's out
there and
i like how you have the artwork above
each one too so that's really neat and
like what we were saying before the show
if you're spending money on the world on
itunes
why don't you use it to help a ministry
yeah there you go
there you go here's something else i
want to share that
what i want to do is one of the projects
that i want to do for the channel
is i want to be able to help people
not just memorize each individual
scripture
but i want to develop a way that
they can memorize let's say 15
scriptures for a topic
so that if they are in a situation they
want to be able to give a bible study
they can do it from memory just by
knowing all the songs for that topic
so i'm working on a scripture song pack
that i've got a couple so far but the
next one that we're working on
is on the topic of the sabbath amen
awesome so doing a scripture song pack
on the top of the sabbath
it's going to have like 14 songs
scripture songs hope to have that
finished in about a month
and then after that have another
the other topic is what happens when you
die
so those are two key topics that is
what we need to know what the bible says
for the time that we're living in
and if i can help people memorize the
scripture for those key topics
man praise god yeah that's a great idea
that is a very
god-given inspiration for you to do that
yeah as you were talking i was like oh
yeah that makes a lot of sense
because when you're wanting to share
your faith with somebody
the more biblical reasoning that you can
you know show them those verses this is
why we believe the way that we do
and you know instead of just one verse
yeah the bible
links a lot of different verses together
that support each other
line upon line priests upon priests i
was just wondering how it's going to be
the tone of music if it's the mark of
the beast
[Laughter]
see mikey could do that
that's awesome that's awesome you were
talking about also about song app right
in the future i remember you were saying
that i would love to be able to
create an app that uses the scripture
songs
people can see the scripture song in
there and listen to it
but then interact with the app in such a
way that
they fill out the scripture oh nice
that they can that would help them in
memorizing it
and then it the app would remind you
on a daily basis and it would increment
then to a weekly basis to a month to you
know over
a period of time so that they're
continually
knowing knowing god's word and being
able to memorize it
and then being able to re recall it to
you to memory
and then that would help them in sharing
it so i would love to be able to do an
app
and so i could um i don't know how hard
it is
to build an app you know you hire
somebody i guess but
one easier way to start maybe have a
like five versions of the same song and
the first time it sings it all the way
through but then it'll be like
uh for for god so love that
that he gave his only begotten you know
and then the next time it's saying
listen that's a little
lyrics so that when you're listening
you're filling in the lyrics
right or something i don't know maybe
easier way to do it
my kids have learned um all the books of
the bible they've learned all the
apostles and all that
through song and it's funny because like
even the um the old testament
like i get i i just from hearing them
sing it like i did not sit down
and sing it with them and learn how to
do it i just they're in the background
singing it right
i can now get through most of the books
just from like
actually hearing it from a distance and
then once it once it kind of gets past a
few it's like they get a little jumbled
towards
i've heard people do it i'm like this
doesn't rhyme or anything i don't know
how you're getting it but
the tune is so like doesn't make sense
but
um it's very interesting but i've heard
lots of different versions of the
matthew mark
matthew mark and luke and john x
yeah i don't know
well you know the abc's you know i mean
my daughters are you know singing all
style
me you know english for me the second
language so you know
you know kind of like i learned about it
by the r s and t
after that i mean i just don't remember
it yeah
that is a powerful thing you know
through music learning things and then
god's word i mean that's just top of the
line i have a question did you learn it
that way in spanish oh no so now
they have a different a different song
but i mean you can sing in
spanish it sounds nice you know it
sounds good but i never learned it in
mexico because she does have extra
letters
yeah that's really okay so and that part
we just wrap it
so that brings me to an interesting
question are you
um do you have any plans to do this in
other languages
wow i've got one song
that we did that was in english and
portuguese
so um i would love yes i would love to
do that
um just gotta get to that level uh
is it uh because of brazil the
portuguese
one of the guys who saw
the channel okay and he reached out
because it's really funny
like as as uh um i have visited
different churches and stuff in
in um brazil uh they're all musicians
like literally the entire church is
musicians and one time they said oh
we're gonna do a church
concert right it was like after after in
the evening
and so i think i was the only one in the
audience i think the entire church was
up there in like different groups and
bands and everything like this
and just kind of fun but i know they're
a very musical culture
that's why i asked and so yeah no i
would love to do some different
languages just
see how the lord leads so if you know
any other languages
and you're a musician and you would like
to help
we'll we'll definitely uh put your
description
uh or the link to where they can find
you you have a facebook page as well
okay so you you uh can find ricky
through his facebook page any of the
questions you guys got for him
man i'm just i'm really impressed with
it i can't wait to
well thank you ricky for coming on the
show and uh what a blessing we'll be
praying for your ministry thank you
and um be looking out for my song that
i'm going to say yeah
all right yeah right you know
you know what i should do we should all
do one as a team together you guys play
indians
yeah i know he plays guitar he plays
[Laughter]
there we go
and alex will take whatever we do and do
it in spanish there you go there you go
[Laughter]
i really do hope that this has inspired
somebody to
say hey i have a talent i'm not even
using it for god here's a great
opportunity you know it might not be an
animator but i can sing it send it to
this guy
yeah man get in getting god's word amen
yeah you know
you mentioned that that made me think
about making god
personal to yourself
through this experience god has been so
close to me it's been great to
to draw close to him and just be and i
love that we can serve a personal god
uh i'll share a short testimony about
having a personal guide i remember when
in in college i just graduated from
college
and it had been about three months i
hadn't found
work yet and i had a small family
but i wasn't able to support them uh
at the time because i didn't have a job
and
and so i was looking for work and and i
was
at at home my mom's house and
one of the this one specific specific
day
it was getting ready to rain and so i
had to go outside to roll my windows up
from my car
went outside rolled the windows up it
was getting ready to come back inside
and i sensed the lord speak to me
in my mind to say hey stay outside and
let's
talk i'm like okay
talk do you see it's getting ready to
rain and
it was a type of a storm that was coming
that seemed like it was going to be a
strong storm because
the trees were just waving really
hard and they were seeing that they're
tipping close to the ground and
and the lord's like yes let's talk it's
like okay stay outside and talk to god
went out in the back porch and and then
the lord spoke to me again my mind said
um what's the matter because i was i
forgot to mention i was
i was very depressed
very sad uh because i had this wonderful
family who god had blessed me with and
so he and so he guys asked me so what's
the matter why are you so
down why someone said well i'm down
because i'm sad
i'm frustrated because you've given me
this wonderful family
but i can't even support them because i
don't have a job
he said and god spoke to me again and
said well
did you ask i was like
no i didn't ask
well why don't you ask
okay god
the mere fact that you're asking me
to ask that's telling me that you're
going to provide
me so i already know you're going to
provide
i just want to know when if you're going
to give me
a job within
six months time let me yeah it was
gonna be six months time let me see two
birds fly by
if it's going to be within um
uh three months time let me see one bird
fly by
now i chose birds this was my fleece
i chose birds because in a storm i don't
know if you ever notice
in a storm the bird is all gone fly away
go home so i said okay if i see a bird
fly 2-1
to me that's god speaking to me
so god if i'm going to get this job that
you're going to bless me with within six
months time let me get we'll see
one bird excuse me two birds if it's
going to be within
three months one bird open my eyes and i
saw
one bird flying from the right to the
left
i was like whoa whoa wow and i said
thank you god thank you so much um i
want to go a step further
if i'm going to get this job that you're
going to bless me with if it's going to
be
within a month's time let me see two
birds fly by
if it's going to be within the three
months as you already said let me see
one bird fly by
so i switched it up yeah
opened my eyes and looked up and two
birds flew from over the trees over the
house
behind me i was like whoa so now i'm
getting
my hair in my hand my arm is raised and
i'm gonna get goose pimples
i was like whoa thank you lord okay
father
i just want to go one step further
and and please i hope i'm not asking for
too much
this job that you're going to bless me
with if it's going to be
within a week's time
let me see one bird fly by if it's
already going to be within the month
time as you've already said let me see
two birds fly by
opened my eyes looked around looked
around for a while didn't see any birds
and i got the sense like man i probably
overstepped my
request you know my quota um and i said
i better go inside and
i'm just going to go inside now and i
started walking to the door
had my hand on the doorknob and the lord
was like
ricky have patience
wait on the lord amen be of good courage
wait i say wait on the lord and so walk
my hand with my hand on that handle
for the door i looked to my right and
there
one bird flew from one tree to the next
tree
okay i was like oh wow
god you're gonna brush me with this job
in a week's time
i run in the house and i'm i remember
i'm praising the lord
i remember the the israelites when they
were in
when they saw that they were in the
presence of god they
threw themselves down prostrate before
the lord
so i went into the living room of my
parents home and i was down
prostrating the ground praising the lord
and right in the middle
of my praise scotty the phone rang
wow so i stop i look up
and i say god are you doing what i think
you're doing
when answered the phone hello this is
ricky uh yes is ricky carter yes this is
he says oh we received your resume and
demo reel
um are you still looking for for work
i said yes i am now mind you this was a
tuesday
okay i said yes i am i said okay well
can you come in tomorrow for an
interview i was like yeah i sure can i
said all right we'll see you tomorrow
give me the address went to the location
the next whoa i hung up the phone
continued praising god of course went
to the interview the next day interview
went well
the following day they called back
offered me the job and i wanted to know
if i could start
on friday and i said yes and on friday
i started working so within a week's
time the lord blessed me so
many all of that to say i want to
encourage
anyone watching to make god personal to
you
god's promises are sure
says to prove him um
i remember there's a quote that i read
in spirit of prophecy
and and i think it's in um the amount of
oh my blessing no um
christ's object lessons it says
something to the fact of
here's the power of god's word she says
that
the same power that was in
every word of god that
that created things brought things into
existence
the same power that's in in his words
that created things is
in every one of the promises of god
amen that's some power yeah so that's
what i want to encourage you
uh with is to make god personal um
claim his promises amen god cannot lie
that's right approve him put out your
fleece
and be encouraged with god's word it's
it's there for us to
help us to perfect us to get us ready to
meet him to spend eternity with him
amen amen amen what a blessing that's a
powerful story and a powerful
illustration
of i i mean you can see the examples in
the bible of of people that have done
just that i love hearing you know
all of the cases where somebody would
come to god and be like okay god
uh i need to know if this is a view and
and do it like this
okay don't be mad at me god but uh if
it's like this right and god's very
patient with us he understands like
you know we're in a different difficult
vantage point here we're like these
little
peons of dirt in the bottom of this you
know
mess of sin and and he's very willing to
work through that with us
and time and time again we can come to
him i mean
there's examples of of people going to
him like moses
and changing god's mind god's like no
i'm gonna wipe them away
and moses was like no god don't do that
you know like you know
just think about what what what what
would happen if you did that
and so you know god is an awesome
personal god and
thank you for sharing us that story but
uh you guys
i hope you are blessed by today's topic
and uh the important thing is is
god is wanting to communicate with each
and every one of us
he has put an amazing amount of
of information about who he is
how much he loves us in his word and if
you get
into his word you will fall in love with
this amazing god that we have
and so here's just a one example of a
million
how to commit those words that god has
told us
to our memories and i believe with all
of my heart
that it will have a major impact upon
your walk with him
and so thank you ricky for coming on
board uh if you guys want
to check out his channel or follow him
and
or even just get involved in his work
we'll put the the link in the
description below how you can get a hold
of him but
thank you for watching led live and
we'll catch you guys next friday
[Music]
given to you it will be given to you
i am the god of the new
i love it i mean i can't watch enough of
this the duelist who they say can speak
with the spirits
the sins will destroy the commandments
forever a suspicious list of names
prompts an investigation at a local
school and concern for parents the death
note is derived from a japanese animated
show the girl told authorities she got
the idea from a cartoon network show
mom it's mr satan i recognize that voice
[Applause]
anywhere
visit our brothers at school for profits
dot tv and watch from babylon to america
which has over 5
million views on youtube alone and
follow it up with america
2 babylon check the description below
for links to this
and more
[Music]
you